millions of americans didn't let high
gas prices in airport chaos keep them at
home this fourth of july a record number
of travelers packed into airports over
the weekend tsa estimates it screened
more than six million people friday
through sunday that is close to a
pre-pandemic high for many of them
flying has been a headache with
thousands of delays and cancellations
nikki batiste is at newark liberty
international in new jersey this morning
nikki good to see you
ed good to see you good morning all
chaos continues at airports across the
country this morning with hundreds of
delays and cancellations at the start of
the weekend tsa screened close to two
and a half million people making friday
the busiest day at airports since the
beginning of the pandemic this in the
middle of growing demand staff shortages
and those high gas prices
i just want to get out of here i think i
had enough the numbers over the weekend
are staggering nearly 17 thousand
flights delayed and more than 1400
canceled the flight disruptions leaving
hundreds of thousands of passengers in
turmoil we just got here they let us
know right now that i got canceled alam
khan's flight from newark to toronto was
canceled days before his wedding i'm
just going to shoot her a call and be
like look babe i uh i'm kind of stuck
here for now but i'll be there as soon
as i can be transportation secretary
pete buttige has been under pressure to
address the chaos this is something
that's affecting all of us and it's
affecting the economy when that happens
because so many people can't get to
where they need to be for work so many
people can't get to loved ones at the
height of the pandemic the airline
industry received a 54 billion dollar
bailout bootage is calling on airlines
to do better we sent a lot of taxpayer
funding specifically for the purpose of
keeping people employed at these
airlines and now they need to have the
people and they need to have the
resources to get people where they need
to go this year more flights have been
delayed compared to any other year in
the past decade
staffing shortage is one of the biggest
factors at play specifically pilots and
just on thursday delta pilots were
protesting for higher pay and better
work conditions
the mayhem at airports may be why 42
million americans are opting to bypass
them entirely this holiday weekend and
hit the road instead
despite the record high gas prices we
want to get back
hit the road do some traveling see the
country
some good news guys alum khan did
eventually make it to his wedding he
drove more than nine hours to toronto
after his rebooked flight from newark
was also canceled flightaware data shows
in the u.s this airport is the most
affected by delays and cancellation
today's so as the saying goes pack your
patience emery
nikki thank you